Spider-Man Spider-Man does whatever a
spider can but cut across the
spiderverse live up to the original
here's what the critics say there's no
question that among fans of comic book
movies 2018 Spider-Man into the
spider-verse is regarded as one of the
best on-screen adaptations to ever exist
Phil Lord and Chris Miller's
mind-bending Multiverse movie is a
delight from start to finish following
Miles Morales as he goes through the
familiar Spider-Man origin story he gets
bitten by a radioactive spider a thus
when things start to get beautifully
strange grieving villain Wilson Fisk
builds a machine that can somehow cross
into parallel dimensions and that leads
to several different Spider-Man and
Spider women meeting up with Miles
problem is with the barriers between
Dimensions breaking down at a rapid rate
staying in the wrong Dimension means
your cells end up decaying so not only
does miles have to battle a number of
villains alongside his allies everybody
needs to get back home eventually the
sequel Spider-Man across the spiderverse
is easily one of the most highly
anticipated comic book movies and
follow-ups set to hit theaters and the
critical embargo has finally broken
again so what do critics think they like
it a lot am I for one can't wait to
watch
this probably won't come as an enormous
shock but according to early Watson
Tomatoes reviews critics enjoyed Across
the Universe quite a lot as Ben Travis
and Empire Rose across the spider verse
cranks every dial to 11 and somehow
doesn't collapse in on itself visually
astonishing emotionally powerful
narratively propulsive is another
Masterpiece screen crusher's mad singer
agreed saying the sequel builds
perfectly on its predecessor expands
into the spider-verse is already
eye-popping animation and even more
audacious directions Clarice Lowry of
the independent agreed writing out of
every Multiverse this is easiest to root
for over at The Daily Beast Nick
Schrager was a fusive in his praise
saying a new stand that has been set
setting a new Benchmark for diverse
agile breathtaking animation Spider-Man
across the spider verse is as striking
as non-life action films Come Peter
Bradshaw at the guardian had a small
caveat but clearly enjoyed the movie
nonetheless saying it's Dynamic and
intriguing though the detail and the
emotion can get lost in the Splurge
meanwhile Brian through it rights at USA
Today that the movie contains multitudes
when it comes to the narrative Arc and
emotional journey the Heart and humor
are still there but a serious side also
permeates the impressive follow-up
considering how encouraging the early
reviews are it's reasonable that fans
are probably getting more excited than
ever for Spider-Man across the spider
verse so what can they expect from the
movie well now that he's in Better
control of his powers as Spider-Man
Miles teams up with his love interests
Gwen Stacy to save several different
spider people from a villain called The
Spot faced with the outcome that the
spot could take down the entire spider
verse miles meets a group called The
Spider society and its leader Miguel
O'Hara and soon finds himself at odds
with their mission Spider-Man across the
spider-verse hits theaters on June 2nd
2023 and fans will finally get to see if
it lives up to the original apparently
they can remain pretty optimistic if
critics are to be believed
[Music]